normalmente los seres son muy poco
reactivos lo que los hace muy buenos
solventes orgánicos sin embargo si los
hace reaccionar con ácidos fuertes
obtienes una escisión ácida del éter si
empezamos con un éter aquí del lado
izquierdo
y añadimos un exceso de haluro de
hidrógeno y calentamos la mezcla el éter
se escinde para formar un alcohol y un
haluro de alquilo
normalmente las condiciones de reacción
convertirán en ese alcohol en otro
alumno de alquilo por lo que usualmente
terminas con dos alumnos de alquilo como
producto aunque no siempre sucede en
términos de que alumnos de hidrógeno
puedes usar hbr y h y son los que mejor
funcionan y esto se debe a que cuando
tienes el año bromuro o yoduro los
electrones están más alejados del núcleo
lo que aumenta la fuerza en núcleo
física de esos aviones comparado con
digamos algo como cloruro en donde los
electrones están más cercanos al núcleo
ya que tiene un tamaño menor
veamos el mecanismo para la decisión a
ciudad de 3
y comenzamos con nuestro eterno
este es nuestro éter
qué vamos a hacer reaccionar con nuestro
alero de hidrógeno
comenzamos con una reacción ácido base
un ácido fuerte como el ácido brom
hídrico va a donar protones el éter va a
actuar como una base
un par de electrones disponibles va a
tomar el protón de
al 1 de hidrógeno los electrones se van
a pasar al halógeno así entonces
terminaremos con vamos a propugnar
nuestro éter
tenemos un hidrógeno ahí tenemos un par
de electrones disponibles en este
oxígeno lo que le da a este oxígeno una
carga formal de más 1
también tenemos a nuestro halógeno tenía
tres pares de electrones disponibles y
tomó un par más de electrones
disponibles para formar una unión al oro
que va a funcionar como nuestro núcleo
film
y ese núcleo filo va a atacar al carbono
unido al oxígeno y luego los electrones
entre el carbono y el oxígeno van a ir
al oxígeno entonces este es un mecanismo
tipo s n 2 en el que el amonal 1 va a
actuar como un núcleo filo bien y es por
esto que los aviones bromuro y yoduro
funcionan mejor que los aviones cloruro
el resultado de este ataque núcleo
físico son alcohol
ahora tenemos un par de electrones
disponibles extra en nuestro oxígeno
aquí
y nuestro grupo r prima está ahora unido
a nuestro halógeno entonces ya hicimos
nuestro primer alumno de alquilo algunas
veces la reacción se detendrá aquí y
algunas veces la reacción continuará
si la reacción continúa podemos
conseguir otra molécula de haluro de
hidrógeno aquí
y un par de electrones disponibles en
nuestro alcohol van a funcionar como una
base y tomarán un protón lo que lleva a
estos electrones hacia el halógeno y
entonces dibujamos el resultado de esta
reacción ácido base vamos a protón ar
'nuestro alcohol nuestro alcohol ahora
tiene dos hidrógenos
de electrones disponibles en nuestro
oxígeno y una carga formal de más 1 y
nuestro halógeno tiene ahora un par de
electrones disponibles extra dándole una
carga negativa convirtiéndolo en una
leona luro en el siguiente paso del
mecanismo el año na luro va a actuar
como un núcleo filo y va a atacar al
carbono unido al oxígeno manda a estos
electrones hacia el oxígeno
y así es como hacemos nuestro segundo
alumno de alquilo formamos r x como
nuestro otro producto
y también se produciría agua en esta
reacción h2o dibujé esta segunda parte
del mecanismo como si fuera un mecanismo
tipo sn 2 y sería un mecanismo tipo sn 2
si hubiéramos comenzado con un alcohol
primario este de aquí es un alcohol
primario y después se protón a un
alcohol primario funcionaría mejor para
un mecanismo tipo sn 2 porque tendría
menor impedimento estético sin embargo
si tuviéramos algo como un alcohol
terciario en este punto la reacción muy
probablemente se daría había un
mecanismo tipo sm1
entonces es importante ver la estructura
del allure o de alquilo hagamos un
ejemplo de la decisión a ciudad de ceres
y comenzaremos con un éter que se ve
algo así
bien vamos a hacer reaccionar este éter
con ácido brom hídrico en exceso y vamos
a calentar la mezcla cuando pensamos en
nuestros productos
sabemos que el éter se va a perder y
sabemos que vamos a obtener dos saludos
de al kilo entonces solo necesitamos
encontrar nuestros grupos al kilo si veo
de este lado aquí está un grupo al kilo
y si veo de este lado aquí está otro
grupo al kilo todo lo que tengo que
hacer es convertir esos grupos al kilo
en alumnos de al kilo iban a ser bromuro
de al kilo ya que estamos usando ácido
brom hídrico entonces voy a dibujar uno
de mis saludos
alquilo así habría un bromo unido al
anillo
mi otro alumno de alquilo será este
grupo metilo de aquí
entonces tomó el grupo metilo y lo uno a
un bromo bromuro de metilo sería mi
producto y también produciría más agua
pero los productos principales serían
estos dos saludos de al kilo
hagamos otro este será un poco más
complicado en tres dimensiones vamos a
pensar en la escisión la ciudad de éter
es en tres dimensiones
lo hace más difícil si vemos un éter que
se ve así y le añado otra vez ácido brom
hídrico en exceso y caliento la mezcla
voy a obtener una escisión la ciudad de
éter y cuando intentó saber cuáles son
los productos sé que el oxígeno se va a
ir y sé que los carbonos que están
unidos a ese oxígeno son los que van a
formar mi saludos de alquilo entonces
veo a este carbono que está unido a mi
oxígeno y ese va a estar unido a un
halógeno y si veo a este carbono del
otro lado de meter ese carbono también
va a estar unido a un halógeno
cuando intentó dibujar los productos
este anillo de aquí va a permanecer
igual voy a dibujar el anillo así
bien veamos primero a este carbono de
aquí el de color rojo que es este de
aquí estaba unido a un grupo metilo aquí
y el enlace entre el carbono y el
oxígeno se va a romper y vamos a formar
un nuevo enlace con el halógeno que es
bromo vamos a poner bromo aquí así en el
lado opuesto cuando vemos este carbono
de aquí vamos a dibujar ese carbono aquí
es el carbono en azul el enlace entre el
carbono en azul y el oxígeno se va a
romper y vamos a formar un nuevo enlace
con el bromo que es nuestro halógeno
entonces vamos a dibujar
a nuestro bromo aquí así y ese sería
nuestro producto obtenemos dos saludos
de alquilo en la misma molécula podemos
dibujar hacia el producto o lo podemos
aplanar un poco pensamos en ese sistema
de anillo de aquí qué tipo de sistema de
anillo tenemos tenemos 12
456 carbonos presentes voy a dibujar
esta molécula de manera diferente voy a
tener un anillo de 6 carbonos un ciclo
hexano y si veo tomemos este carbono de
aquí que es este carbono
que está unido a ese carbono pues
tenemos que este carbono está unido a
otro carbono hay dos grupos metilo y
luego un bromo así no importa realmente
el orden en el que colocar los grupos
metilo y el bromo ya que este carbono de
aquí no es un carbono quiral no te debes
de preocupar por eso y veamos a este
carbono de aquí abajo en color verde le
pondremos color verde a este de aquí
hay un grupo metilo unido a ese carbono
haré que un grupo metilo
una a este carbono de aquí y también hay
un bromo unido a ese carbono estas son
sólo dos formas diferentes de
representar la misma molécula para el
producto de una decisión ácida de
electro original una difícil porque
estás pensando en tres dimensiones aquí
hagamos un ejemplo más de decisión a
ciudad de éter es comenzaremos con x
hagamos stephen y el éter
dibujaré un grupo fenol aquí está
nuestro grupo fenol y luego tenemos un
grupo estilo de este lado
entonces cuál sería el producto de etil
fenil éter más ácido brom hídrico
en exceso con calor aplicado a la mezcla
pensemos en el mecanismo sabemos que en
el mecanismo el primer paso es protón ar
el éter el éter va a actuar como una
base toma un protón del ácido brom
hídrico voy a dibujar el primer paso
la reacción ha sido base
vamos a proponer nuestro éter
y eso significa que va a haber un
hidrógeno unido unido al oxígeno
ahora un par de electrones disponibles
sigue estando en el oxígeno
tienes una carga formal de más 1
tenemos el año bromuro solo después de
que hr dona un protón
r negativo se queda
e la unión bromuro va a funcionar como
mi núcleo filo y va a continuar con el
mecanismo tipo s n 2 por lo que va a
atacar al grupo alquiló con menor
impedimento estético que por supuesto es
el grupo alquiló de la derecha un par de
electrones disponibles van a atacar a
este carbono de aquí y estos electrones
van a irse al oxígeno si dibujo el
resultado de este ataque núcleo físico
el anillo ahora está aquí y acabo de
convertir todo en un grupo o h
bien porque ahora tengo un oxígeno con
dos pares de electrones disponibles así
entonces hago fenol como uno de mis
productos y el a neón bromuro se acaba
de unir a un grupo de tilo vamos a
formar entonces un bromuro de tilo como
el segundo producto bromuro de metilo
sería nuestro otro producto
voy a marcar estos carbonos estos
carbonos son estos carbonos de aquí en
mi producto y resulta que esta reacción
se detendrá en este punto entonces estos
son tus dos productos fenol y bromuro de
etilo la reacción no continúa y
pretendemos que la reacción continúa y
veremos por qué se detiene aquí si
continuáramos con el mecanismo protón
haríamos el fenol tenemos hbr aquí de
nuevo la adición de ácido brom hídrico
protón haríamos el fenol si protón
haremos el fenol justo aquí
obtendríamos algo que se vería así
con carga formal de más 1 en el oxígeno
y también formaríamos el año bromuro
y si este mecanismo continuará de manera
usual
el año hombro muro actuaría como un
núcleo filo y atacaría a este carbono de
aquí en el anillo
pero ese será un problema si hablamos de
un mecanismo tipo sn 2 porque el anillo
vencen y ccoo tiene todo para presentar
impedimento estético y evitar el ataque
de ese año hombro muro como núcleo filo
debido a ese impedimento estético el año
en bromuro no puede atacar no hay
mecanismo tipo sn 2 aquí para formar
otro al 1 de alquilo eso no funcionará
que hay de un mecanismo tipo s n 1 si
esto es un mecanismo tipo s en eeuu no
necesitamos formar un kart vocación y
estos electrones de aquí se pasarían al
oxígeno
y podríamos formar el carb ocasión de
este modo con una carga positiva en ese
carbono el problema con este carbó
catión es que no tiene estabilidad por
resonancia no podemos dibujar
estructuras resonantes que ayuden a
estabilizarlo y por lo tanto un
mecanismo tipo sn uno no puede funcionar
tampoco no hay mecanismo sn uno para
convertir todo en un segundo al uno de
alquilo y no hay mecanismo tipo sn 2
debido al impedimento estético y es por
ello que nos quedamos con el fenol como
producto y bromuro de tilo como otro
producto sólo una luro de al kilo se
produjo en esta reacción